History is full of stories of demons and other unearthly creatures coming into our world
and wreaking havoc on society.
But what does science have to say about zombies?
Are these ferocious freaks plausible or scientifically accurate in any way?
Should we be preparing for a zombie apocalypse?
Well, it depends on what type of zombie we are talking about.
Dying and coming back from the dead?
Not so likely.
But a virus that induces zombie-like qualities of rage and the incessant need to eat human flesh?
Hypothetically.....yes.
The main factor involved is finding a virus specific to the brain areas for these symptoms
while leaving other areas intact.
Neurons are some of the some of the longest cells
and can transport molecules and proteins across the entire body.
Many viruses such as rabies take advantage of take advantage of something called
Retrograde Axonal Transport